- Est-ce que ça se pourrait
qu'il y ait des choses
qui soient disparues de
la caisse de Mononk Jules?
- Jocelyn Sioui a découvert
l'histoire de son grand-oncle
Jules Sioui en fouillant
dans une boîte appartenant
à sa famille.
JOCELYN SIOUI, idéateur, auteur,
interprète, "Mononk Jules"
- Au tournant des années 40,
les réserves... les gens dans
les réserves en avaient assez.
Puis, c'est là qu'arrive
Jules Sioui, qui met
un peu d'huile sur le feu
pour enflammer les passions,
ce qui fait que les gens ont
décidé de changer les choses.
Mononk faisait jamais rien
comme tout le monde.
- Jules Soui est un Wendat
qui a éveillé les consciences
grâce à ses efforts pour rallier
les nations autochones du pays.
Fin des années 40, il est arrêté
pour sédition. En 1950, il fait
une grève de la faim de 72 jours
parce qu'il se sent injustement
persécuté par le gouvernement.
- C'est une plongée...
voir comment la justice
traite les affaires autochtones.
Donc, les réponses du juge,
comment le juge parle.
À un moment donné, le juge dit
un commentaire, par exemple :
"Il a été lent comme tous
les Indiens qui se respectent."
T'sais, c'est un juge
qui dit ça. Ça nous remet
dans une époque : OK, on est
rendu vraiment ailleurs, là.
- Vous avez jugé bon de
faire croire au public que
les Indiens sont des sujets
britanniques et qu'ils sont
tenus de faire du service
militaire obligatoire.
- Jocelyn Sioui parle de
son grand-oncle et de ses luttes
à l'aide d'une douzaine
de boîtes magiques.
- Ça, c'est mon plaisir,
je suis marionnettiste, fait que
moi, les bébelles, j'aime ça.
T'sais, tantôt, tu parlais
de Robert Lepage, là, s'il y a
un "bébelleux", c'est bien lui,
mais je pense que je suis autant
"bébelleux", mais en miniature.
J'aime les petites affaires!
(rires)
J'ai de plus en plus
la conviction que les gens
sont des musées fragiles.
- L'histoire a un peu effacé
Jules Sioui, qui est tombé
dans l'oubli, en partie
parce qu'il a été reconnu
coupable de grossière indécence.
- Et là, je me suis mis
à réfléchir aussi sur tous
ces personnages-là qu'on tente
de déboulonner, qui ont fait
des grandes choses, puis
qu'on aimerait effacer. Puis là,
je me suis posé beaucoup de
questions, puis c'est encore
plus actuel en ce moment,
parce qu'on est là-dedans.
C'est rare qu'on nomme
le nom des Autochtones
dans l'histoire canadienne.
- "Mononk Jules" est présenté
à Montréal jusqu'au 6 novembre,
puis à Québec au mois
de décembre.
- Je sais pas si, il y a 10 ans,
le spectacle aurait été présenté
de la même façon. Je pense pas
que les diffuseurs se seraient
intéressés autant. Je pense que
par force des choses, à force
de nommer, depuis #IdleNoMore,
depuis les commissions,
il y a eu un éveil collectif,
puis je pense qu'en plus,
cet été, il y a eu la...
l'allumette qui a allumé
le grand feu.
Sinon, comment
vous expliquez qu'on en sache
si peu sur l'histoire
des Premières Nations?
- Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada,